Welcome to ICT for dummies episode six time
Yeah, um anyways guys. Oh, yeah, oh we're flexing
This is gonna be a pretty simple session
This is foundational knowledge that you should a hundred percent know and it's gonna help you with trading a lot today
We're gonna be going over the five most significant sessions Blake. Okay, so what I have here is kill zones
So what kill zones are are going to be the best times to be trading in the market since we are trading the Nasdaq
We are trading Nasdaq futures and we are also trading ES and the S&P 500 futures
This is all going to be an Eastern standard time now for 4x kill zones are different
So please note that if you're gonna be trading 4x there are different times
But since we are just trading ES futures and enqueue futures
These are the times that we want to be paying attention to now. We have five different sessions here. All are very important
We have Asia session which starts at 8 p.m. Eastern to 12 a.m
We then have London session and Asia session does tend to be a lot less
Volatile and choppier because not a lot of New York traders are trading during this time same thing goes for London session
You're gonna get a little bit more volatility from 2 a.m
To 5 a.m
And then New York a.m
Session is going to be when the market has the most volatility and it's also going to have the cleanest price action because this is
When the New York traders are trading during this time now 830 am is going to be when news is released
So 830 is also still technically pre-market and 930 a.m
Is actually when the stock market opens so when the New York Stock Exchange opens is at 930 a.m
That is that opening bell and that is going to be when a lot a lot of volatility kicks in but 830 a.m
Still is part of the killzone time
You also have New York lunch hour in New York p.m. Session New York lunch hour
Obviously is not gonna have a lot of volatility
There's not gonna be a lot of people trading during this time and just like the name entails like people are typically on lunch breaks
There's not a lot of traders during this time
Directly correlating to the fact that there's not gonna be a lot of volatility or volume then you have New York p.m
Session this typically does have a bit more volatility in volume
But not as significant as New York a.m
Session for the most part on some days New York p.m
Session might have more volatility than New York game session
But most days New York a.m
Session is gonna be your best bet at finding just the best opportunities in the market since the most amount of traders are gonna be trading
During New York a.m
Session this is gonna have the most consistent price action and it's gonna generate the most consistent results
With our strategy and with ict concepts in general. Yeah guys for beginner traders
I highly highly suggest just focusing on New York a.m
Session you should not be trading during a session one in session lunch hour
Now these times are significant because they are going to be really high probable liquidity pools, which we'll get into later
So still knowing these times is very very important. And despite the five prominent sessions we have marked out in front of us
I can't emphasize it enough focus on mastering one that is the most effective way to becoming profitable
that is the most effective way of mastering a strategy because the thing is
People are heavily mistaken a lot of beginner traders often think that they need to trade every single session
But that will negatively affect your results, please
Please take my word for this and other traders will tell you the same thing master one session
That is how you will understand your strategy best
That is how you will master your strategy best and that is how you will consistently see the best results in the market
Some of you may have some sort of inconvenience that is just overlapping with the New York a.m
Session whether it is work school or whatever it may be and therefore you can't trade New York a.m
Session and maybe your only option is London session or New York p.m. Session. That's fine
Just know that obviously New York a.m
Session is gonna be the best in general
but if your only option is for example London session just make sure you're mastering London session and not going and not
Experimenting with every other session cuz gonna screw you over like Patrick was saying more trading
Does not equal more money getting made in the market
I always see beginner chairs also like asking us like why don't you trade like every second of the day does that mean you?
Can just like make the most amount of money no by focusing on only one session
Not only are you going to be getting the cleanest trades the cleanest price action the best volatility
You're also going to build yourself a lot of discipline by only taking you know
One or two trades and then closing your charts for the day because in reality that's what the best traders do
They take one two trades a day and they are done
You guys do not need to be trading every single session
You don't need to be looking at every single session also screen time in general
Does not equate to looking at the charts all the time that doesn't equate to good hours for screen time
Yeah, you understand that it gets to a point where you start seeing diminishing returns
With your screen time right if you're just spending your entire day looking at every single session
You know you trade New York game session you take a couple of trays and you look at New York lunch hour
And then you look at New York p.m. Session like you're not really
Learning as much as you think despite the fact that it may feel like you're learning by looking at all these different sessions
The reality is that it is not as effective as you may think like you don't want to be a slave to the charts
You don't want to spend your entire day looking at them
And if you want to just practice mastering a session then you can go ahead and back test go over 30 days of New York
Am session price action stuff like that is what actually helps you improve
Just some general knowledge is that since Asia session and London session are typically far less volatile than a.m. Session
That is because it is typically saving most of volatility for New York game session
However, there are times where you will see Asia session dump or pump
Hundreds of points and when you see this it's typically a sign not to trade a.m. Session, right?
These overnight moves are extremely large usually will generate bad price action for a.m. Session
This doesn't happen too often
But you should be able to identify when it does and it should be an easy sign for you to tell yourself
Okay, I probably shouldn't trade today because we had a huge overnight move and this pretty much goes for every single session for example
Let's say New York am session is super super clean, right?
We got a really large move to get out some prominent buy side or sell side liquidity
Well, then you can expect that New York lunch hour to then be a lot choppier and a lot slower now
We're gonna go over some examples of how sessions move and how may impact a different session. Okay guys
So I use this indicator called ICT kill zones and pivots
You can go up here you click indicators and I do not use a lot of indicators
This one is super useful
It's by trade for off and it basically marks out every single session as you can see here marks out Asia session from 8 o'clock to 12
AM then marks out London session from 2 a.m. To 5 a.m
And then New York and from 8 30 to 11 now you guys can pause the video
Screenshot if you want these exact indicator settings also the reason you're seeing that in the indicator settings 8 30 is not included in
Session it's just because we don't typically trade pre-market. So we just started at 930
But if you want to include pre-market you absolutely can we just like to start off the New York AM when the New York Stock Exchange actually opens
Does you guys can see here? When is price action the most volatile? When do we get the best movement?
Well, it's obviously going to be during New York AM session, right?
And that's going to be from 9 30 a.m
To 11 a.m
And then after that we typically have a lot choppier a lot slower price action and it's not the best as you can see
You have also Asia session and London session the market sure is moving but is not nearly as significant as what you're seeing in New York AM
Session now since these are killzone times we still will have pretty significant moves
For example, we did go for around 200 points in the overnight session
But the moves just aren't going to be as clean and they're not gonna happen as fast like when you're trading New York AM session
Your take profits are most likely going to hit a lot faster versus when you're trading London session
You're gonna have to wait a lot longer and here we have one final example just for good measure as you can see on the left
You have Asia session, right? The range is not really that big London session
Once again, also just not that big and then as soon as you get that New York AM session at 8 30
We also have news though here so you can see that extremely volatile candle
We're gonna show you how to identify news real quick
But then you can see New York session opens up and we have a lot of volatility getting pumped into the markets
That's a 930 candle and yeah, it's a lot of movement. That's a lot of fucking movement
If you're new to trading, you're probably wondering what was that candle and like Patrick was saying
It's a news candle. So we're gonna get into news and how to know when this news is going to be released
Okay, so this website is called forex factory comm
So forex factory is going to tell you when news is released. You're gonna want to go over to the top right of this bar
Right here. This is your filters
So pretty much the only two folders that you want to be focusing on is red folder and orange folder news
Yellow folder does not really do anything orange folder also really does not do anything
But there's times when orange folder could so it's always good to be just aware of that and the currency you just want to click
USD if you're just trading indices and if you're trading forex then well you want to be clicking all of these but since we're just
Trading indices just focus on USD and then event types you select all I want to change this for them
What the fuck is that
What the fuck is chihuahua time? Okay
So this is all of the news for this week of February as you can see we have news today at 10 a.m
So Powell is going to be speaking. You don't want to be trading when news is released
Okay, I'll give yourself like a five minute time frame window from when news is released
I would wait about five minutes after news is released before you start executing trades
Just because even though that news candle may be at 830 or maybe at 10 a.m
Right those couple minutes right after that news candle are also gonna be super super volatile
What and before it's going to be really really choppy like Blake said so usually like the five minutes before news gets released are
Gonna be like super choppy and price will just wick around everywhere news gets released huge frickin candle pumps into the market
You dip you typically don't know which direction it's gonna go
So avoid being in a trade before that and then of course a couple minutes after news
You're still gonna be there's still gonna be a lot of volatility in the market
Just kind of finishing off that news candle
So wait about five ten ish minutes before you execute this will just help you avoid getting chopped out of a trade
So really the main news events that you guys want to be focusing on is CPI
So CPI and PPI is typically on a Wednesday or Thursday or Thursday or Friday
This is happens once a month and it always happens at 830 a.m
Eastern you again you do not want to be trading during this time
You want to be trading after that news is released and I want you guys to know also that it is okay to be trading
On days when there is red folder news
It's actually going to be a lot better and a lot more volatility in the market a lot cleaner price action when news is released
Because a lot of traders are going to be trading there's going to be more volume now for these days
You might want to be sizing down because the candles are gonna be a lot bigger
Versus, you know days like Mondays where we typically don't have any news. The candles are going to be a lot smaller
So you're gonna be able to put on more lot size put on more risk
also note that one of these super volatile news days is gonna be
NFP non-farm employment change and that's gonna release on the first Friday of every month
I this is considerably like one of the most volatile days
So definitely make sure you're risking down on a day like NFP and also know that before a day like NFP
Price action typically won't be as good think back about how we were talking about with sessions when we were saying a lot of the
Volatility saved for a New York a.m
Session and therefore Asian London won't be as volatile think about that sort of with news, right?
If you have NFP releasing on Friday
Thursday typically won't have a lot of volatility in the market because most traders are waiting for NFP to be released before going about
The markets and once again to reiterate how what Blake was saying before
Your two most significant things to look at are just read in orange folder news orange folder typically doesn't do much
but it is still really important to be worried about it because
Sometimes it can generate like an 100-point candle
So just definitely something to pay attention to we also said make sure your currency is on USD, right?
You can see that in the currency spot right there since you are trading the NQ and ES
Which is a Nasdaq futures in that some P 500 futures
You really only care about USD FOMC you also want to be paying attention to so FOMC happens from 2 30 to 2 30 p.m
How will come on stage and there will be a statement and there will also be
So how will speak and then there will be a statement and then there will be a press conference going over
Basically what he just said and that is again from 2 to 2 30 p.m
So typically on FOMC the New York AM session will be not very good price action
So you typically don't want to be trading really at all on FOMC. It's going to be pretty hard
I do not suggest trading FOMC days for beginners at all and just avoiding that day in general
but on these days it is actually okay to be trading like up until 4 p.m because there's going to be a lot of
Volatility in the market and again AM session won't be that clean PM session will be clean
I'm going back to our liquidity video
We will have a lot of liquidity
But it just won't get taken during AM session and that's basically just bad price action, right?
Because for example here like we were saying if there's going to be that news that's released and this day was
NFP as you can see we just left a lot of liquidity. We weren't taking it
We were just leaving these swing highs leaving these swing lows until finally news is released and then it just takes out all that liquidity
I didn't say like that news is released
So guys just remember the most important red folders to look out for it's going to be CPI PPI
FOMC NFP anytime Powell speaks and that's pretty much it
I mean those are definitely the most significant ones but any red folder, you know
Just avoid being in a trade before then and just give it a bit of time after releases to trade
But yeah, thank you guys so much for watching I see T for dummies episode 6
Oh
And yeah
If there's one thing you're gonna take away from this is that your job should be to master one session screen time
Does not mean trading every single fucking session on the planet. Yeah, make sure to like subscribe
Comment, let me know what country you're in drop that in the comments. Let us know and
Yeah, boys follow the socials much love peace out boys